[Music]
so my name is Shane glass I am the
program manager for Google clouds public
data set program yeah but more
importantly today I get to be the MC for
demo derby so demo derby is this like
cool fun thing we do internally and it's
a really neat part of our culture Google
is a really big place and there's a lot
of really cool things happening across
Google so this is an opportunity for
developers and people that don't always
work together to get to see the amazing
work that their teammates are doing and
get to better understand it so I will
get out of your way I know you guys are
here to see the fun I'm here to see the
fun so without any further ado let me
bring up our first developer advocate
Billy
[Applause]
long walk to the stage hey everybody I
am Billy I am a in developer relations
for cloud BigTable and I'm going to talk
to you about my demo of air quality
monitoring and analysis how big tables
are massively scalable no sequel
database and it's perfect for an IOT use
case so we put sensors like this in the
back of a few Google Street View cars
and our monitoring air quality live
right now actually we have a few cars
right on the road driving around the San
Francisco area let me zoom in a little
bit I think if we wait a few seconds we
can actually watch it move around the
data is streaming in here through
pub/sub we've got like a 4g connector on
here it sends messages to pub/sub
processes it with data flow and then
writes it to BigTable we also had a
collection of three years of historical
data so we visualized that as well and
created an interactive dashboard with
this big table is perfect for serving
serving an application because you get
really fast writes and really fast reads
so so here we're able to look at the
last three years of data let me see my
zoom might be a little off sorry now
we're looking at the ozone concentration
we've also have nitrogen dioxide and
these cars are driving all over the Bay
Area we can even check what happens when
they go out a little bit farther
sometimes sometimes they just stay in in
the area you can really see we're
getting data at a street-level position
and this is only some of the data that I
was able to visualize without the math
getting too slow because there were too
many data points on there and also a big
table we have the really fast read so
we're able to do training directly on
our data on our data in BigTable
we don't have to move our data to GCS
or another kind of fast storage system
so we're doing nitrogen dioxide
predictions based on zip code and date
so we can click somewhere in the map and
get a prediction for the nitrogen
dioxide values and yeah we'd also change
the date like August or something and
see if it changes it's not we didn't do
a great job trading the model we're
really just trying to show the proof of
concept a big table is great for an IOT
workflow great for doing machine
learning on top of here's some of the
architecture we've got going on let me
see there's n so yeah we've got this
beacon streams to pub/sub to data flow
and then to big table and for the batch
data we can just get it streaming in
right from cloud storage or maybe
bigquery for the machine learning we
trained our tensor flow model on compute
engine and then we host that with cloud
machine learning services and on the
front end we're accessing that with a
cloud function and this is all just
being hosted on an app engine server
that's hitting all of these endpoints
yeah that's all I have to demo I think
we doing some questions now
all right let's have a big round of
applause for Billy Billy I was actually
afraid that was a gateway computer that
you were bringing over here yeah I was
like oh it looks like a whole computer
yeah so we have any questions we have
microphones over here on stage left and
right please come on up and ask your
questions now this is the first this
week was the first day I actually got to
see one of the sensors in person so that
was pretty cool all right well in that
case I'll ask you a question all right
go ahead how do you guys differentiate
and understand what the impact of
natural disasters like wildfires are
compared to what you would see in a
normal kind of high-traffic environment
I'm not sure of that so we were able to
get this data from an internal team
that's working with acclimate provided
the sensors so they're taking the more
scientific initiative doing data
processing cleaning up the data as it's
coming in we were able to just hook into
their live data stream and their
historical data and they have big plans
I'm going to add more cars and do more
analysis with that yeah so the plan is
then to to kind of bring this out
further and expand it yeah I think in
the coming months they're gonna be
adding like maybe 20 cars or so and
that's just in the Bay Area I think the
goal is to expand to other areas other
countries and see where things go all
right so what should the the good folks
here in front of us be looking forward
for after that after that yeah like what
would they see from this from this view
as that happens as that happens well
hopefully more points would be filled in
because right now we can only see where
the cars are but that's also kind of why
we've wanted to show the machine
learning so the cars can't be everywhere
at all the time so how can we create a
heat map of where the cars might have
been that past year around that time or
based on the other points around there
awesome look so we have a question over
here
hi so I was wondering with the data
you've gathered
are there any sort of findings that
you've concluded in terms of like health
implications in certain areas of the
city or if there are any sort of you
know rise in asthma because there's like
co2 that's like aggregated I think there
have been a few thanks for your question
I think there have been a few more like
scientific papers written about some of
this information and I don't have the
answer based on that though so you can I
can describe you after and point you in
the right direction on that any other
questions okay all right well Billy
thanks so much we really appreciate your
demo let's hear it again for billion
thanks for having me okay yeah we
appreciate your holdin questions I mean
we're asking these folks to go really
fast because that's the fun of demo
derby is it's a Derby so yeah feel free
to come on up at during the session and
and kind of queue up and ask your
questions
speaking of which we are really lucky to
have our next presenter developer
advocate here at Google Zak
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Zach I'm a
developer advocate for machine learning
I'm based in London and does anyone want
to guess where my accent is from no one
has ever gotten it right okay that
person got it right yeah I'm from
Ireland and I like machine learning and
I've built a really cool machine
learning detector and it's pretty
obvious what it is right like it's I
think it's spelled correctly so a bit
about me I'm Zack I build stuff I build
stuff that matters this is a decisive
thing that will decide if you should eat
something that's on your desk or not you
can find a bit more about that
on my Twitter but I want to talk about
what I built for this demo derby and I
don't know about you but I love tech
videos who here likes tech videos like
everyone I love tech videos and you know
I work in tech it's great I get to hear
tech tech tech all day long but when I
go home I swapped check views but just
like there's too much tech jargon in
them am i right
like I want to watch the tech video I
want to get all the techie goodness but
I don't want to hear about the tech I
want the tech video without the tech you
yeah I get everyone has this sort of
problem yeah I want tech videos without
the tech and so luckily I managed to
glue together some tools to achieve this
now I don't know if you've been on the
floor yet but if you've been over near
the AI section we actually have a demo
that shows our video intelligence API
who here is to use the video
intelligence API or heard of it a couple
of people yeah so we had this demo and
it shows us some of the capabilities of
the API and one of them is object
tracking so it will do sort of a base
object detection and it'll do all that
for you you don't need to train the
model but it also does this cool thing
which is transcription so if you've ever
used the text-to-speech it's basically
the exact same API that runs alongside
but it just saves you having to scrape
out the audio from your video file so
you give it you give it the video tell
it transcribe it and I will do it the
cool thing about it is that when it
transcribes it not only does it tell you
the whole block
hex that is in the video but it'll tell
you a per word when each word was said
at a specific second in time so this is
interesting I could potentially use this
to maybe build a build an app that will
find the words that I don't want to hear
and maybe beep them out for me so that's
cool I can I could potentially do that
but hearing the words is one thing I
mean seeing the person move their lips
to the word that's just as bad as
hearing the word because speaking in
conferences you you learn a bit of
lip-reading so is there some other tool
that we can use to solve this so we have
the vision API and what that does if
you've used it if you see upload an
image of a face and tell it you're not a
robot it will detect the individual
points of your face for you they'll do
this with pretty good accuracy so then
the task is simple we take the video
intelligence API transcribe it to take
the words we'd want to hear run the
vision API find the position of the
mouth and then with that information we
can beep at the audio and beep out the
mouth so I've recruited my friend Greg
or nut Greg oh that's terrible
Gabe cause it's recorded so Gabe Gabe
he's a good friend of mine I've known
him years this is him I've taken this
video today he built this really cool
edge demo and I got him to say someday
one of you builds we built a demo that's
doing vision intelligence with a model
that we built in Auto amount on GCP
and it compiles down to OCR
classification to run on our demo it
compiles it down to the edge TPU so that
we can run it locally that's a great
video
it's far too techie for my liking so
I've run the video through this pipeline
I've created and I enable some date what
have you built we built a demo that's
doing vision intelligence with a model
that we built so that's my demo thank
you hey that's awesome thanks Zach
I think that's actually the first time
that I've ever seen you confirm that
you're not a robot yeah so that's
actually a huge relief for me does
anybody have any questions crickets you
just did such a good job explaining it
that mustard is I gotta admit it's not
every day that you see someone forget
the name of a guy that's blue hair I
know yes it's embarrassing
I actually have a question for myself ok
domain please please I would love to
hear your Inquisition sir okay so this
demo was built for my specific use case
of not hearing certain tech words that I
don't like the real use case that I
initially came up with as you may or may
not have come to that conclusion
yourself is that in a speech
transcription API they have a little
flag that will detect any profanity or
swearing that's in the video
transcription and it'll label it with
asterisks is a strict sigh as strokes
stars label it was dishonest so you can
run the exact same pipeline that I've
created here but had it bleep out the
swear words for you so that was the
original use case and I thought the
coolest thing I was gonna see this week
was that picture of a black hole oh yeah
well this is this is cooler obviously of
course it is of course okay was someone
who does not like hearing the tech words
and much prefers hearing that high pitch
beep I really appreciate it so let's
hear it for Zach thank you very much
thank you
playin plug and plug this okay vamp uh
so how's it going so I was told I wasn't
allowed to do a comedy show today
obviously we're gonna cancel the last
two demos and that's what's gonna happen
so I just flew in from Pittsburgh and
boy are my arms tired how about that
airplane food though yeesh
tough crowd alright let's let's not do
this let's go back to the demos as we're
getting set up here
let's hear a huge round of applause for
the team that put together devs own the
devs own theater this was an awesome
event that gave us an opportunity to get
the communities together to experiment
to categorize our pizza correctly and to
celebrate pi day so huge shout out to
the teams that worked so hard on that
and made that happen without any further
ado let me get out of the way the cat
Ben it's all you hi so I didn't actually
get the memo that we were supposed to
have intro slides and so my name is me P
bingo and I'm a cat with a snorkeling
thing anyway so my name is Ben I'm a
developer advocate on the dev ops team
one of the things I'm interested in is
monitoring and in particular I'm
interested in like you know system
monitoring basic system and stuff so we
have stack driver stack drivers pretty
cool but a problem that I have with it
is that you only get data once a minute
so it's a 60 second interval which is
fine most of the time for historical
graphs and stuff like that but sometimes
you want to know what's happening in
real time real time like real time
metrics are very important for like
debugging in a hurry
and also like our brains are very good
at pattern recognition and so if we see
like graphs all the time when you when
there's an anomaly on the graph your
brain is gonna recognize it because your
brain knows something's not right here
because it's used to the pattern that
it's used to seeing and so you can do
that with this but if you have those
graphs in real time you get that
feedback much quicker and so I've always
been interested in how do you get in for
out of these things and into something
that you can actually see in the real
world I'm also interested in doing
extremely stupid demos and so I built
you this box this is the graph I'm at
three thousand I know it's gonna be a
little bit hard to see but I'll show you
a little bit better in a second
so it's got these nine buttons on it
that light up and they represent
different like metrics so across the top
there's a user system and IO eight CPU
the second row is memory usage in like
just regular usage and then buffers and
cache and then the bottom row is a disk
in network i/o so how many people the
developer keynote yesterday you saw the
thing about pi yeah excellent so I
thought I'd do a little bit of that just
to it's a good way to like tax a system
to really kind of show what that system
can do so I've got Y cruncher here this
is what am I used to do the PI thing and
I'm gonna run it and I'm gonna run just
the just a like basic multi-threaded
benchmark keeps everything in RAM and
they'll start running and in a couple
seconds we should see this went
read/write nice so that's telling me
that I'm using a lot of CPU so if this
was just like sitting on my desk be like
alright cool that's a lot of CPU I don't
really know what that means so I can
just like hit the button and wait a
couple seconds and it's very slowly
printing me out of graph dude oh god
that's bad sorry let's go go I'm just
gonna go away
all right so here's graph let me see if
I can fix that real quick I would like
to say that in the like time-tested
demo thing I didn't even have time to
commit this code you saw that like we
brought the laptop up here right as I
got on stage whereas everyone else
already had their laptops on screen or
on stage that's because I was working on
this literally until just now all right
so here is a graph of CPU usage thank
you
so the other thing the other thing that
why cruncher can do is it can do like
stress testing so you can say it's got
all these stress tests built-in that
allows it to you know really work
different parts of the system you can
see those little bar graphs is like this
one is more memory intensive this one's
more CPU intensive so this is just the
same thing but I wanted to show you that
this act of this box actually does
something more than just that one thing
so it should be I don't know if you're
gonna be able see it's gonna be turning
yellow at some point and then red as it
gets started my favorite part of demos
is when you wait for something that
might not happen so it looks like I got
some colors yeah yeah all right cool
well let's leave let's get a memory
graph this kind of debugging tool is
really really handy for situations where
you know that you've got a problem and
your infrastructure is on fire but
you're not actually in a hurry to fix it
so we go a little memory usage graph so
the what I want like God go away
yeah so like what I'm what I'm
interested in here is getting data out
of your monitoring system and putting it
in front of you in some way that's
actually more useful than just having
graphs on the screen so maybe you have
like you know the classic kind of
traffic light that shows your build
status maybe you have a bunch of vu
meters or some kind of like displays in
your office that show you the status of
your system it's important to have that
stuff in front of your eyes all the time
so that when something goes wrong you
see it before the computer tells you
about it so this is a stupid demo of
something you can do like that but like
take these ideas and do something more
interesting with them I guess I didn't
tell you how it actually works this is
really special again in in the whole
live demo thing so what's happening is
this has a Raspberry Pi in it that is
tethered to my phone and is opening a
reverse SSH tunnel to a machine that I
have running in GCP my laptop I am SSH
to that machine and then through the
tunnel back down to the Raspberry Pi to
run stuff manually because I could
didn't have time to figure out how to
like set them up with services and stuff
like that net data is running on the the
PI calculator machine to get real-time
info where's there's also data from
stackdriver but like I said you know if
you got a 60 second interval so we're
getting real-time data from that net
data and then we can look at the graphs
from stackdriver and when you hit a
button it's pulling that data and
printing out a graph so that's how that
all works
I really recommend not doing it how I
did it but doing something like that so
any questions
all right let's hear what's here for
Beth thank you
all right so just real quick can you how
many digits of pi did you calculate uh
oh that's a good question let's look the
reason I asked I was doing the math
along in my head I wanted to see who got
further yeah so let's see probably I'm
gonna guess
somewhere in the vicinity of 4700 83
yeah that's like six so I think you want
them cool yeah all right any questions
all right thanks so much Ben all right
the last demo of the last demo derby
here in the dead zone theater last but
certainly not least Alexi
hey everyone my name is Alexei I'm a DA
I'm based in Paris and I sometimes you
slide I have to I'm sorry spreadsheets I
have to admit and sometimes I do things
like that you know import and go and
look you know maybe on my dock on on my
file system and have some CSV you know
up and open this and then go through
some formatting yes I want this and it's
really error-prone and I thought maybe
we could automate this and maybe as soon
as some data is ready in CSV format I
can drop this in a bucket in cloud
storage and put through some magic of
cloud functions I can have this data you
know just automatically appear in my
spreadsheet so let's see if we can get
to do all this from a project that I may
or may not have been using and testing
but other than that it has just two
storage buckets and that's all there is
to it it's a brand-new project and see
if we can build a cloud function that
will put the data straight into into
that spreadsheet so the thing that I did
do is enable the Google sheets API
that's great I said that I did have a
bucket that bucket is empty this is
where I will be dropping my CSV files so
let's actually go to clap functions how
many people are using cloud functions
just a few actually quite a few
let's create a function that I will call
here a sheet updater
can I type yeah that looks great
this is triggered on stuff being
uploaded to a bucket so this sounds like
the right trigger let me pick a bucket
here select that and let's use node
right and let me show you a little bit
of the code here this is the default
snippet what I have is something a
little bit more involved so let's look
at this is this this is my function
it's an async function it will just
check that the metadata that's passed to
me which is the file that has been
uploaded is actually a CSV file I will
get some authorization and initialize a
Sheetz API and then I will do a few
basic things which is create create a
new sheet which is a new tab in a
spreadsheet read the data the CSV format
and then populate the sheet and those
through things I can do in parallel and
do some styling and make sure I just
freeze the first column the first line
and the way this is done is fairly
straight for it especially when Ronnie
reading from cloud storage the way you
talk to the sheets API is by sending
JSON requests basically so in this case
I will send a something that asks to
talk to this spreadsheet which in this
case is a variable that will be passed
to the function as I create it and then
I have a bunch of code which is
documented and I will tell you how to
get to it
so let's actually create that function
let's go and also Express some
dependencies that it requires which are
typically the storage and
the sheets API and say okay I need to
tell it which actual function to execute
this is function to sheet this is what I
call it and there one more thing that I
need to do actually two more things
okay this region works for me this thing
is important this is the service account
this is the user that will be basically
accessing the sheet on the behalf of
this app so we'll get to that in a
second but but remember this what I do
need to add and this is kind of a
variable that can be changed without
touching the actual function is the
spreadsheet ID so let me type this
spreadsheet ID and the spreadsheet ID is
actually if you know this guy in the URL
of any Google spreadsheet so let's just
take this and paste it here and create
the function so this will take a few
seconds the code that I have here I can
show you just briefly how it uses the
sheets API and for instance when I want
to do some reformatting I can do things
such as you know give it a sheet ID
which is the tab ID that I have and then
do some styling which is get some things
that's bold some font size and new do
number of things that are that might be
useful here if I go to the project
remember that service account there's
one that's created for me by default so
let's actually take that you email
address which is again the service
account that is used by the project to
access the sheet and give it access to
my sheet so just as you would invite any
particular user give it edit access and
just actually I'm sending this I
probably shouldn't share this there's no
human being behind this is my project
and as I do this let's go back to the
function that has been deployed and
let's see if this thing actually works
let's go to my bucket and let's see if I
can drop something here like take the
CSV file which is a few hundred
kilobytes which will translate into a
few
thousands or maybe tens of thousands of
lines and oh wait there's a new tab here
and it just takes this name and here's
the data so what I did here is thank you
I do have some formatting here freezing
the first row making things bold and
that's it my business users or myself
can actually start and making sense and
dicing and slicing the data and then
using all the powerful features that
cheat effort and that's what I have for
you as a demo and this is actually fully
document and then there's even a code
lab so you can follow step by step
through everything I just did and tailor
this to your knees thank you very much
all right thanks so much Alexis you said
the function uses JSON to talk to sheets
I'm glad there's a step-by-step guide
it's Shane proof and because I usually
talk to sheets like muttering under my
voice to myself in a way that is might
require Zak's demo are there any
questions in the room
awesome well thanks so much Alexian at
700 Roman plus for Lexi and for all the
great speakers that we had today
alright well before we go I'm gonna hand
it back out to Jess but I I sort of say
thanks so much for coming out we hope
y'all enjoyed next hope y'all enjoyed
this the demo derby and and enjoy it a
little bit a little piece of the Google
culture so go forth and and do great
things
[Applause]
[Music]